hey guys in this video we're gonna look
at the best hairstyles for men with
short hair now short hair has always
been very popular because it requires
very low maintenance
meaning you never use a lot of shampoo
and conditioner to wash it and you never
need to use a lot of styling products
it's very easy to style and it looks
great so what are the best hairstyles
for men in 2020 well that's what we're
gonna look at in this video let's get
[Music]
the buzz cut now this one never gets old
because you don't need any styling
products because it's already styled by
being short
so no maintenance but just make sure you
got a good skull shape before you try it
and if you have an oval face shape or a
rectangle face shape then this hair cell
will probably look good on you the crew
cut with fade now this one will never go
out of style the length can be very
short on top or you can leave it a bit
longer which is what I prefer because
then you can style it in different ways
like the side part or messy textured
style or spiky side-swept now of course
is up to you how you style it and it
will fit in great with most face shapes
and then especially with a beard too
high and tight now this one is like a
cousin from the crew cut because it's
very similar the only difference is the
high end Titus cuts short all the way
around the side and back of the head and
then the hair on the top of the head is
left longer now this is my prefer the
hair style but I don't like it too long
on the top but a little bit shorter
because then it's more athletic and it's
easier to style and also it fits in with
most face shapes next up is the quiff
now most guys with short hair will look
good in this style is especially good
for men with a receding hairline because
when is longer up front and shorter
everywhere else it looks like you have
more hair and just remember not to pull
it too far back and also if you do have
a big forehead don't put it up to a high
because then your face will just look a
lot longer and
the side sweep now this one is a classic
and is really good especially for those
guys with straighter hair and if you
don't want your hair to be too short and
for this style you normally want your
hair on the side to be a little bit
longer so your barber will usually cut
it with a scissor about an inch and a
half but if you want you can also cut it
shorter now remember this is a nice and
natural look so you don't want to add
too much product because you want your
your fingers to kind of just run through
your hair now if it's your first time
here on my channel remember to subscribe
and you might like one of these videos
and I'll see you there
cheers guys